good morning we are representatives from
st. Patrick's cool cowboy I'm ray I
medicine I'm tom we're here to present
ideas likes and concerns about the red
zoned areas in KY boi pines beach and
hide a key the 3d model was at our
school on the tenth of februari 115
students ranging in age from five to 13
viewed the model and provided their
feedback in the form of 300m six flags
from the three hundred and six flags
more than half with business related and
just under a quarter were recreation
related other ideas were around housing
roading and were related we had a lot of
new ideas most of them will be a lot of
fun but unrealistic because the number
of business ideas will so large we
thought would break it down as you can
see food and beverage was most popular
than retail services and entertainment
with an xmas light we like the idea of
new businesses and carefully we also had
a lot of recreation ideas so we broke
that down too we mostly like sports
facilities and we really like the idea
of a dull park we would also like to see
playgrounds horse training parts and
water activities our concerns we had
like concerns like the other schools I'm
too many shops and convenience stores
could equal into road and parking
problems stores and shops near local
schools could encourage kids to do
school too many techies may cause
obesity in pop we desired businesses
could not fit into the budget and too
many shops
could equal shortage of employees
recreation ideas most of our ideas run
carp is so so we've taken a closer look
at their area firstly we looked at
recreation we support lots of recreation
space and some of our ideas for that
space will hockey turf dog park swimming
park soccer park nipple chords and I
scaling back business ideas within car
please because the number of business
ideas were large we thought it might be
a good idea to break down the ideas for
part ways most business ideas proposed
and highway east would
entertainment-related EG opera house
theater / movie theater town hall and a
bowling alley one tenth of the ideas
were retailers EG warehouse more and
comic stores more than half of the ideas
will food and beverage belated EG
chocolate factory pizza hut dunkin
donuts mendes we support the ideas
proposed in the draft bone it will be
good to see the red zone area is moving
forward we think more areas to play and
hang out with friends and family is a
good thing we think it will be good
additions [ __ ] we thank you for this
opportunity
you